now then the Scottish National Party
will launch a new case for Scottish
independence this summer whatever the
outcome of EU referendum it's only 18
months of course since Scotland voted to
remain part of the United Kingdom well
I'm join now by the SNP's business
spokesperson Hannah Bardell she's live
at their conference in Glasgow very good
morning to you Hannah Bardo what's all
this about it and you independence
referendum campaign your own leader said
it was a once-in-a-generation vote what
this is about is seeing that we respect
the outcome of the referendum and 2014
but we want to continue to make that
case we are the Scottish National Party
we are the party of independence that
has never changed but we want to
continue to stand up for Scotland
against Westminster's austerity cuts and
to make a positive case for independence
to show that Scotland can be prosperous
and can be a nation that stands on its
own two feet and does things differently
as we have pruned in government in
Scotland take a lot on board but what
about the once in a generation bit um
you know that's got to be at least what
20 30 years well what we have said very
clearly is that this will be a matter
for the people of Scotland therefore
people have Scotland decides and there
is you know demonstrable evidence that
another referendum is what the people of
Scotland one then we will listen to that
and we will put that forward and we will
continue to make a positive case for
Scotland being able to be an independent
country you know we recognize that some
people wearing convinced by our argument
since the first minister said yesterday
we are doing things differently in
Scotland we are making people's lives
better against the backdrop of
Westminster austerity cuts do you think
part of that listening to the people of
Scotland as you put it clearly garba
referendum about having a referendum so
you're just going to listen do you think
you will hear the cry come more loudly
if the UK as a whole should vote to
leave the EU
all the pools are suggesting a majority
of people in Scotland are against
leaving the European Union that's not to
say that they're not people that do want
to leave but we believe that we should
be have the opportunity to make that
decision for ourselves not be dragged
out against our well as part of the
United Kingdom and you know it's
disrespectful to the people not just of
Scotland by the rest of the euchy to be
rushing into this EU referendum you know
less than well around six weeks after
we're going to have had elections and
the devolved a administration's across
the UK you know the independence
referendum and Scotland changed politics
it gave people the opportunity to have a
sea and their own future and to really
engage and understand what a yes vote
would look like we're not going to have
that opportunity in the EU referendum
because David Cameron is rushing to the
finish line to try and get us a 2 c'n
without making the case positively and
engaging people in the way that we did
when we set a gold standard for having
referendums but when it comes to making
your own decisions making Scottish
decisions in Scotland a lot of people
listening are going to be say well
source for the goosey etc what about
this sunday trading vote I mean first of
all the reports are that the SNP ratted
on a deal with the Conservatives to
abstain offered Stewart Josias seat in
the Privy Council and things like that
but the S&P ratted on that deal to calls
the Conservative government
embarrassment
well what I would see derma is you
shouldn't believe everything that you
did in the place and I was part of that
engagement with businesses individuals
trade unions you know to lessen and to
understand what the concerns were and we
were very clear at the time when the
proposals were brought forward and we
were very clear last week this was about
premium pay for some of the purest paid
workers the lowest paid workers not just
in Scotland but across the UK and it was
very clear to me and to my colleagues in
the SNP that if those changes were made
to kind of a potential knock home and
impact to those receiving premium p so
we had no option but to vote against it
mmm convoluted formula some would say
well what I mean what happened when it
came to fox hunting then what was your
economic argument there when you your
veto the equalization of the laws in
Scotland in England sorry could you
repeat that question I didn't quite
catch at my up so you got previous
haven't you of meddling in so-called
english-only Affairs which Nicola
Sturgeon said she wouldn't do when it
came to two changes to fox hunting to
make the law in England and Wales more
or less the same as that which pertains
in Scotland again the SNP embarrassed
the government on that one was there an
economic argument for that well there
was an argument from people not just in
Scotland but across the UK content cat
started contacting us in vast numbers to
see they wanted us to vote against this
so you know we will always do what we
believe is the right thing for not just
Scotland but the rest of the United
Kingdom while we are stuck part of the
UK and while we are still part of
Westminster we said that we would be a
progressive force and Westminster and
when we would work with others to pursue
progressive policies and that's what we
did specifically in the case of sunday
achieving how many people contact you
these vast numbers about fox hunting how
many people from England
oh well there was certainly for my sale
hundreds you know if you multiply that
across the various members then you know
that's that's a significant number but
you know the poison rationalization of
all the 60 million this is a nation of
the UK has more than 60 people in it but
well do you want to get an argument
about you know the details of Fox
something or do you want to talk about
the real issues that are facing us you
know such as the budget next week the
kind of cuts that are going to be coming
down the lane from the Chancellor you
know the EU referendum all of the
parties you know the two main parties
and Westminster labor and conservatives
are split over this the SNP continues
with your strong and united voice to
stay in the EU to make a positive case
well with respect miss Bardell we we are
talking about important issues the
judgments that the SNP makes when it
comes to to voting on UK matters and
matters that affect England and Wales
and not it seems Scotland the judgments
the decisions you make to do that
absolutely and in terms of sunday
treatment it was very clear that there
was going to be a knock-on impact not
just for Scotland but for the rest of
the UK in terms of those war pedes
workers in the retail sector so we were
absolutely clear it was the right thing
to do the government in contrast was not
able to bring forward it to an impact
assessment till the day of the vault how
disrespectful is that to Parliament and
not just to the voters in Scotland but
in the other parts of the United Kingdom
so you know we worked with all of our
colleagues across the house to
understand what the concerns where to
also understand what the concerns were
across society and the retail sector I
mean any change in ian's and it was very
clear there was there are people who had
questioned those judgments but on the
issue of fox hunting now you be very
clear about this that the SMB made that
made the judgment to oppose that the
change in the law in England and Wales
because of the number of English people
who had contacted you therefore the SNP
is making of judgments that it
represents people who who don't vote for
it you can't vote for it because the SNP
doesn't stand south of the border that
you represent them as well
what you know as we said in the 2015
election we would be a progressive force
we would work positively with other
parties were there were opportunities to
protect you know not just the people of
our of these islands but you know the
the animals the wildlife we've just you
know done a quite a significant campaign
on saving the the wildlife crime unit
which the UK government was going to
pull funding from that's headquartered
in my constituency in Livingston and
we've secured funding over the next four
years so you know there is another
example where we are willing to lessen
not just two people in Scotland but
people across the UK and it was people
in spot on the contacted us as well but
there was a great opportunity to you
know do something positive and and sieve
you know the wildlife and the foxes and
in England and in other parts of the
United Kingdom okay must stand it there
and about Dell thank you very much
indeed